[Music]
you got spots and some ads you got cast
no appetite a lot of a lot of
commercials yeah that's how it was
paying my bills yeah you know we were
looking around looking for early ads one
of the earliest ones you do that made a
big change for you because you got paid
was an ad for juicy fruit gum yes that
paid all my bills for almost two years
yeah really wait for two years
understand because they were one
commercial it's one commercial but
there's no dialogue in it so they are
able to sell the commercial to multiple
countries and so I would get residuals
every 13 weeks and when they stopped
playing that commercial it was just such
a loud reality check oh my god I need to
get a job you really think for a while I
got the juicy fruit at i/o I am getting
a bigger closet
you know that's a really I looked at the
ad it is a weird ad yeah because my
pants fly off yeah I don't really know
what it has to do with it's very weird
look for that in a gum yeah gonna make
my pants fly off yeah all right yeah I
mean I think you it looks like it took a
while this shoots a very strange head
let's roll that out
take a look
[Music]
got a half sweet we've got a half juicy
fruit nothing satisfies like it juicy
through the got a sweet
[Applause]
you
you